I'm calling out all the parents if
you're a parent and your child is in
prek to elementary school elementary
school to high school I'm calling you
out the children today I have never
exper and I'm I'm
22 having to teach and work with you
guys' children has been the most
traumatic experience of my life I teach
5-year-olds
ballet 5-year-old girls ballet I have a
class of 10
students they don't respect any
Authority you ask them can you stand in
your designated spot they're telling you
no and shut up they're throwing things
at each other they're throwing things at
other people other classmates you say
can everybody sit in their spot I don't
want to I'm not doing that you don't get
to tell me what to do you're not my mom
you confront the parent the parent tries
to argue with you and fuss at you
because you tried to reprimand and
redirect their kid I told a young little
girl please sit in your
spot you're not my mom you don't tell me
what to do okay when her mom came to
pick her up I said hey your daughter's
having a hard time following
instructions and seven times today I've
had to redirect her to just sit in her
spot well clearly she didn't want to sit
and mind you this is a mom clearly she
didn't want to [__] sit right there
so I mean if she telling you she don't
want to do something why keep asking her
to do it you know she not going to do it
what world do we liveing
[Laughter]
like I'm laughing cuz it's absurd
why because it's it's just like you send
the kid to school for instructions and
the parents like well clearly she don't
want to follow instructions and I'm like
but that's that's what you sent your kid
from it's often time sometimes parents
that had trouble in school or hated
school and stuff like that they get
parent they get they get kids and then
they're gonna be like it's like the it's
like their revenge on the teacher oh is
that what you think yeah yeah you told
me when I was a kid you ain't telling my
daughter I know you guys ain't [__] so F
you too and they back up their kids the
way they would wanted to be back up like
they don't grow they don't understand
sometimes that hey you [__] up back
then and maybe your teacher that was on
your back maybe there was a reason for
that or maybe your teacher was your bag
but your that teacher still has a job to
do but yeah what in you guys's brain as
a parent says hm my kid not following
any directions is a is a great thing
it's not that serious and y'all don't
have a right to tell her what to do it's
sad it's sad it's really really sad and
another thing that's heartwrenching is
horrifying it is
horrifying your 5-year-old daughters are
asking to listen to Pound
Town and
ski your daughters your 5-year-old
daughters are asking can we hear pound
sound I'm playing them that is wild can
can I use your phone 2 seconds no you
use yours Noz the sound is not that good
it's not that good kids singing along to
Drake's Rich baby
[Music]
dad
you don't know what that song says hands
on your knees that s b that ass ho let
that coochie
breathe is it all I could be enough bend
that ass over bow let that coochie
breathe breath yeah shake that ass lady
hands on your knees you said lady ma'am
you said hands on your knees ma'am I bet
I bet I bet be hands on your
knees shake that ass Drake shake it off
of me oh well that was a weird lyric
Shake That Ass for
Drake now shake that ass for me now bend
that booty over bow let that coochie
breathe yeah shake that ass lady hand on
your knees hands on your knees that's
what they saying hands on your that's
what they
saying it's just that the thing is we
had all crazy F we had crazy song it's
just that the songs were more subtle
back in my days um yes and no you know
don't want no short dick man was not so
subtle but Madonna Like A Prayer um that
[__] was not really praying okay I want
to take you there take you where Evans
you know what I'm saying
uh our [__] was a little bit more subtle
than B that [__] uh let that coochie
breathe um none of it was kid
appropriate I remember none of it I
remember being in middle school but it
was the same thing and this memory this
is like probably one of my most Vivid
Middle School memories I think we were
like nine mhm and there's three girls oh
it was a white girl an Asian girl and a
black girl okay we're holding hands and
we were playing uh we were playing we
were playing football European and these
three girls were holding hands skipping
through the field saying
what my neck my B my what coochie and my
CRA yes and I'll never forget it I
literally can still see their face I
don't remember a lot of people from that
time I don't even remember their names
except for one of them cuz she was bad
but I remember them running through the
field I think Young Folks been listening
to a lot of this stuff yeah they've been
five is is crazy I don't remember
remember it being that young yeah and I
don't remember parents sitting around
just oh wow let's film this and post it
cuz it's cute nah that was stuff you
heard when you wasn't at home and your
parents couldn't supervise you but that
was much older not at five five is crazy
five means your parents playing that
[__] for you your kids are not finding
that at five you playing that for your
kids you playing that around your
children then I got to start to look at
the parents a little bit like what is
y'all
doing like what is you guys doing buts
go ahead no yeah that's a lot the
5-year-old is a bit a bit
much but your kids the difference is
really like the kids have access to a
whole lot more for me back then at five
when I was five for me to have access to
even hip-hop living here for me to have
the things I would have to do to just
have access to hipop I would have
actually my parents would actually would
have to want to drive to New New York
that's what my where my family was and
we' had to bring a tape cassette video
cassette VHS and go there Rec press
record and bring that [__] back home all
right not forgetting to bring it that
that's what I the extent I have to do to
have videos from the states or videos
like that okay now is Mommy give me your
phone and if it's not locked for uh
parental whatever which isn't most of
the times they have access to all that
listen so what you listening to your
kids are listening to as well yep
Princess
Tiana ballet
music and they are asking me can we hear
P you know what pound to
is other name it's okay you don't have
to tell me
anymore pound town
listen let's just my booty all around I
don't know what to
do I don't know what to
do and I'm so scared for these little
girls today because this is the most
insane insane agenda push I have ever
seen in my life it is so crazy how women
can be so well put together say so many
smart things and have those ugly [__]
Nails it is like I'm like I'm with you
and then I see the
I tried ignoring it the minute I saw the
nail I was like oh boy here it goes
because they feel the need to also put
it in front of their face IA going to be
tripping and there he is tripping right
now okay you know what I'm going to keep
my mouth shut I'm G to stop talking
about the nails you can talk about it
but but but but for the fs watching did
y'all not think the same thing as me
when y'all saw them Nails it's like man
you so well put together everything
there some people and those Nails I'm
just like okay you got guys's daughters
are twerking at
5 where's the parenting I'm going to be
honest that's a super American thing
because yeah it is when I was even like
I just saw people Twerk it all the time
when I was in like Miami or even Los
Angeles like it was really random not
even like black folks that's all that
Laos just like there's something about
them they just like twerking it's it's
Miami everything I remember going to one
party we were just twerking there like
music is off and they still twerking and
I'm just like
this is really weird I've traveled I've
been to a lot of parties everywhere the
like we twerk anywhere anytime with no
music and music that is a uniquely
American thing sometimes it's just one
day happy they want to put a hand in the
air and go hi once you hear hi sometimes
I don't have to turn I'm I'm
[__] sing where they
hi ooh [__] oh this drink is busting H
the minute I hear hi I'm like this [__]
is twerking right
here
[Laughter]
exactly that that's [__] the minute like
you ever having a conversation with
someone you just look and they're just
twerking there's no music it's not even
a party just like okay y'all yall
different that's all how was I was I was
uh how was your trip oh my God it was so
much fun we had so much fun
to the [__] is wrong with you how did
when did twerking become punctuation
what the [__] I
just I just asked you a normal ass
[__] question so working is no longer
a dance it is punctuation it is a word
know I know bro it is an idea it is a
philosophy I know it is a lifestyle so
yo so did you yo so you went to that
restaurant how was it oh my God like the
best friend that was the bomb shrimp it
was just oh my
what the
ah was so fun what are you doing K what
happened what happened to the word good
it was good no it's like
what and you know exactly what I'm
talking about because you're laughing
like that you've seen this [__] I've
practiced it why is you guys'
5-year-old's daughter singing P
town
and it's just really really really It's
upsetting bad and I I I've watched
different
techniques soft skills soft parenting
gentle parenting I'm patient I don't you
know I don't
yell I'll say Hey you know let's regroup
you guys need five minutes let's do some
breathing your kids are telling me to
shut up you guys' kids are saying I
don't want want to do that I'm not doing
that you're not my mom they're putting
their hand they're hitting each other
and hitting other
kids you address the parent the parents
are telling you you don't tell my
daughter what to do it's not that bad
well at least she was in the class at
least at least at least it's all these
excuses y'all come in and you're more
worried about what's going on on your
Instagram and Tik Tok feed versus being
a parent be a
parent you guys are horrible parents
like I'm sorry to say it she's going to
have an awkward next class cuz this
video went viral and some parents about
to what did you say about me and my
parenting [__] I bet you she not at
that same place teaching those kids I
guarantee you that you think I would
highly doubt it if a video like this
goes viral I run a studio and you're one
of my teachers and you say that you got
to go cuz you cos me too much money so I
already know the studio owner is trying
to get rid of her I know the parents are
complaining cuz went viral and they know
kids are in her class there's no way
ain't no way this went super viral yeah
uh yeah there's absolutely some people
who don't parent their kids some people
are just happy to get get rid of their
kids for a few hours they'll sign them
up for a [__] ballet or whatever but
have no desire to follow up to be
involved in the process they think as
long as I just pay money they're going
to learn a skill that's just not how it
works that's not how it works you're
just neglecting your duties and you're
paying money to make someone else have
to deal with your problems cuz that
child is your problem that child is your
responsibility and you're paying money
to send that kid over there so they can
be somebody else's problem for a little
bit so you can get some rest Spike from
the [__] little undesirable monster
that you
created that's C and that's why a lot of
public teachers just quit like a bunch
of public teachers are watching this
girl like amateur I dealt that [__] for
20 years
25 and they just quit because they said
the pay is not worth dealing with these
sometimes not the kids is the parents
that they be mad at the kids are just
reflection of the parents choices so a
lot of them can't even correct these
kids or do anything to actually help
anything because then the parents
complain so then their jobs are at risk
so now you guys are seeing
firsthand what it's like for a lot of
people have to do with these kids and
people if you can't handle it uh get out
of the job oh don't worry it's happening
teachers are quitting in mess a lot of
schools are having trouble finding any
teacher to teach your shitty kids you
know what you guys doing when you're
doing that when you're not raising your
kids like that you're raising the price
of your next kid and Generations after
that because all those teachers are
quitting then the school's going to have
to increase the the pays and who's going
to fall on that the parents the parents
the next generation of parents going to
have to pay because all you people
messed it up you messed it up you sent
your bum ass kids to school all the
people all the the teachers went out and
quit wanted to quit and then to get more
better teachers I'm going to have to
increase the pay yeah I have to nobody's
going to show up for the job I'm going
have to either increase the pay or get
horrible [__] teachers yep setting
the Next Generation for failure and
that's what you're doing I said before
and I'm going say it again some of y'all
[__] don't want to be parents
you want to have
kids that's going to be one of the best
slogans that we have on this channel
absolutely and that that is that is 100%
a fact I've seen some of you little
pieces of [__] uh roam around the street
it's crazy they cannot function in
public and that's your fault it's really
bad to say to someone and people really
think it badly when you say oh you're a
bad parent bad some of you are
actually a lot of you are there's a lot
more bad parents than good parents out
there but you know the best part is you
can turn it around you can turn it
around but the the minute the minute you
started in that pass it's really hard to
pick back up I I feel like hey once your
kid is is six and you've been shitty
parents till he six well throw throw the
kid in the crash yeah a lot of these
people are Kings of Their Own Little
Kingdom so when you got that kind of
authority someone else on the outside
question is like yo what the [__] you
saying about my kingdom worried about
yours right that's how they acted it
makes me think of managers who get their
position and just stay stagnant the
whole time and think they always know
best even though the industry is
evolving or whatever these guys are
still stuck in their same stupid ways
because they have a bit of power that's
how I feel like a lot of these parents
operate 100% yeah it's fine it's fine to
say yeah you're trash at your job and
you're raising a little [__] piece of
[__] who's going to be worse for
everybody else afterwards yeah I it's
okay to say that that's that's just
facts anything else you want to say no
all right let us know what you guys
think in the
comments
down